let's jump back to it artificial
intelligence what's your thought of the
state of where we are at currently with
artificial intelligence and what do you
think it takes to build human level or
superhuman level intelligence I don't
know what intelligence means that's my
biggest question at the moment and it's
I think it's cuz my instinct is always
to go well what are the foundations here
of our discussion what does it mean to
be intelligent how do we measure the
intelligence of an artificial machine or
a program or something can we say that
humans are intelligent because there's
also a fascinating field of how do you
measure human intelligence of course but
if we just take that for granted saying
that to whatever this fuzzy intelligence
thing we're talking about humans kind of
have it what would be a good test for
you so during develop a test that's
natural language conversation would that
impress you
a chatbot that you'd want to hang out
and have a beer with of you know for a
bunch of hours or have dinner plans with
with is that a good test natural energy
conversation is there something else
that would impress you or is that also
to differ yeah I'm pretty much impressed
by everything well I think if Roomba if
there was a chatbot that was like
incredibly and I don't know really had a
personality and I if I didn't be the the
Turing test right like if I'm unable to
tell that it's not another person but
then I was shown a bunch of wires and
mechanical components and it was like
that's actually what's you're talking to
I don't know if I would feel that guilty
destroying it I would feel guilty
because clearly it's well made and it's
a really cool thing
it's like destroying a really cool car
or something but I would not feel like I
was a murderer so yeah at what point
when I start to feel that way and and
this is such a subjective psychological
question if you give it movement or if
you have it mmm act as though or perhaps
really feel pain as I destroy it and
scream and resist then I'd feel that
yeah that's beautifully put and less
say act like it's a pain so if you just
have a robot that not screams just like
moans in pain if you kick it yeah that
immediately just puts it in a class that
we humans it becomes it we
anthropomorphize it it almost be
immediately it becomes human
yeah that's technology question as
opposed to sort of a physics question
right I think that's a really good
instinct to have you know if the robot
screams screams and and and moans even
if you don't believe that it has the
mental experience the qualia of pain and
suffering I think it's still a good
instinct to say you know what I'd rather
not hurt it the problem is that instant
can get us in trouble because then
robots can manipulate that and you know
there's different kinds of robots as
robots like the Facebook and the YouTube
algorithm that recommends the video and
they can manipulate in the same kind of
way
you